escribe 15 a 25 como una fracción
simplificada muy bien 15 a 25 es
simplemente una razón 15 a 25 y esta
razón para escribir la coma como
fracción la tenemos que poner como un
numerador dividido entre un denominador
y ahora para simplificar lo que tenemos
que hacer es encontrar el mayor número
que divida tanto a 15 como a 25 su
máximo común divisor dividimos luego
estos números entre ese número y
obtenemos la fracción simplificada
notemos que 5 funciona porque 5 divide a
15 y a 25 y si hubiera un número más
grande seguramente lo vamos a poder
detectar después de que simplifiquemos
entonces déjame dividir arriba y abajo
entre 5 entonces aquí divido entre 5 y
abajo también divido entre 5 y que nos
queda esto es igual a 15 entre 5 es 3
dividido entre 25 entre 525 entre 55
entonces nos quedaría tres quintos y
ahora 3 y 5 ya no comparten divisores
mayores que 1 por lo tanto ésta
ya está simplificada esto sería la
respuesta o si quieres lo puedes
escribir en esta anotación como 3 a 5